منظمه هيومن رايت صور السلطات المصريه
ترفض منهجيا في السنوات الاخيره اصدار
الوثائق الثبوتيه او تجديدها لعشرات
المعرضين والصحفيين ونشطائح حقوق الانسان
المقيمين في الخارج اشيرتنا الى ان الرفض
يهدف على ما يبدو الى الضغط عليهم للعوده
الى مصر ليواجهوا الاضطهاد شبه المؤكد
بحسب تعبير البيان الصادر عن المنظمه
واضافت منظمه ان سلوك السلطات المصريه قود
قدره المعارضين في الخارج على السفر
والعيش والعمل بشكل قانوني واحيانا هدد
قدرتهم على الحصول على الرعايه الطبيه
الاساسيه والخدمات التعليميه او لم شملهم
مع افراد اسره اسرهم الاخرين وهكذا منظمه
يورو
قابلت السته وعشرين معارضا وصحافيا
ومحاميا مصريا يعيشون في تركيا والمانيا
ودوله افريقيه وقطر واستشهدت المنظمه في
بيانها بما جرى مع الزميل المذيع في
الجزيره مباشر احمد طه حين عقب مسؤولون في
السفاره المصريه في الدوحه تجديد جواز
سفره حين رجعهم في ايلول الفين 2021 ورغم
انهم اعادوا جواز السفر لسبيل طه لكن
محكمه عسكريه مصريه اصدرت لاحقا حكما
غيابيا في حقه بالسجن لخمسه عشر عاما